[Musica]
ondate di innovazione stanno cambiando
il mondo
la tecnologia sta cambiando i mercati
sta cambiando le imprese il lavoro come
lo conosciamo oggi non ci sarà più tra
vent'anni non meno non ci sarà nel modo
in cui oggi lo conosciamo i miei figli i
nostri figli faranno un mestiere che
probabilmente oggi non ha neanche un
nome e se pensiamo che internet negli
ultimi vent'anni è cambiato la nostra
vita la nostra società nuove ondate di
innovazione stanno per arrivare nel
mondo sono tecnologie che cambieranno la
nostra vita si chiamano stampa 3d si
chiamano blog chain
si chiama rob robben da tutte le parti
si chiamano la nuova mobilità una nuova
urbanizzazione quanto un computing e
quindi quello che pensiamo sia stato
tanto in questi ultimi anni in termini
di cambiamento nei prossimi anni sarà
ancora più forte ea da 25 anni mi occupo
di tecnologia
mi occupo di innovazione e occupo di
start up di venture capital e ho avuto
la fortuna di trovarmi nel 1995 in
olivetti
era l'anno in cui erano gli anni in cui
nasceva il web in cui internet diventa
va gradualmente una cosa di massa e
diventava quello che oggi noi vediamo
e per chi ha vissuto quegli anni su
internet
erano anni entusiasmanti erano in cui
c'erano ogni giorno delle cose nuove
incredibili che stavano succedendo e che
chiaramente avrebbero cambiato il mondo
per cui una mattina andare in ufficio
per cavi il computer sul sito di wired
appariva un rettangolino nero era il
primo banner pubblicitario e quindi
quando vedevi questo banner e vedevi che
era nata la pubblicità online ti rendevi
conto che dietro questo pixel c'era
un'intera trasformazione dell'industria
della comunicazione dei media della
pubblicità è un altra mattina ti
collegavi andavi su una pagina al tempo
internet era una roba così in bianco e
nero non c'erano i colori non c'era lo
streaming
è un tizio di nome jeff bezos aveva
cominciato a vendere libri dalla propria
pagina internet
e dietro questa cosa dietro questa
pagina
chiaramente chi era li vedeva ci sarebbe
stata una trasformazione epocale nella
nostra società nel commercio nel retail
nella logistica nella maniera in cui
compriamo e vendiamo le cose stava
nascendo il commercio elettronico
così un giorno ho scoperto la musica la
musica digitale o scaricato per la prima
volta un file musicale digitale un file
mp3 una nuova tecnologia che era appena
saltata fuori e gente come me chi ha
fatto tutta la vita musicista il
batterista appassionato di musica
immediatamente di fronte a questa cosa
ha visto un cambiamento epocale ha visto
il fatto che per i musicisti non c'era
più il problema di stampa ronci di
trovare una casa discografica riuscire a
farsi promuovere sulla radio riuscire a
raggiungere i propri fan
la musica era diventata digitale e stato
in quel momento che ho capito che volevo
cambiare la mia vita e quindi fatto il
manager
la prima fase della mia vita e ho deciso
di cambiare la pelle e di fare
l'imprenditore e così una sera con due
amici come tutte le start up in birraria
eravamo a discutere di questa idea di
fare un azienda che facesse musica
digitale un sito in cui centinaia di
migliaia di band di tutto il mondo
avrebbero potuto mettere la propria
musica e distribuirla e promuoverla
digitalmente in tutto il mondo senza più
vincoli e senza più le problematiche del
mondo fisico si chiamava vitaminic è
chiaro che quel primo business pence un
tovagliolino di carta erano ancora
semplicemente delle idee noi non
sapevamo come fare ma avevamo fatto i
manager sappiamo come fare una start up
dove andare con chi parlare e
soprattutto non hanno i soldi per farla
ed è stato a quel momento lì della mia
vita che ho avuto la fortuna di
incontrare il venture capital il serino
piol che è stato il mio investitore è
stato il mio mentore fu l'amministratore
delegato di olivetti per tanti anni
stato un precursore non solo della
tecnologia
come mi sto delegato di rivetti ma è
stato uno degli inventori a livello
mondiale del venture capital nel cir
capita è stato inventato a new york e a
ivrea dall'olivetti a quei tempi la
apple che era una piccola startup
californiana di cupertino mandava le
proprie persone ebrea per capire ma cosa
state facendo l'olivetti con questa cosa
delle start up e il serino ha finanziato
più di 170 start up nella sua vita
aziende che ancora oggi tutti noi
utilizziamo aziende che hanno inventato
è però hanno prodotto i microprocessori
che stanno nei vostri telefonini aziende
come yoox aziende come tiscali e aziende
come la mia start up e lui c'è una frase
che dice sempre sulle start up e mi ha
sempre detto mi ha detto guarda editori
io ho finanziato più di 170 start up
nella mia vita e ho sempre finanziato
pmi piccole imprese
tizi come voi che vengono un business
plan su un tovagliolino ma non ho mai
finanziato aziende nale e questo è il
venture capital capitale paziente che ha
il coraggio la forza e la capacità di
investire su nuove idee di imprenditori
che vogliono cambiare il mondo questo è
lo spirito del mestiere che faccio e c'è
un aneddoto che quando ero in olivetti
ricordo molto bene che è stato per me è
importante un giorno era la macchinetta
del caffè e c'era un mio collega stava
chiacchierando e mi ha detto guarda mi
sono licenziato da olivetti di come come
di céline senza la toga olivetti cioè
sta esplodendo il web
sei in olivetti una delle aziende più
belle della tecnologia al mondo e ti
licenze per andare a fare una start up
con due amici e san francisco detto se
come se il pazzo cioè stai facendo un
mega errore
un anno dopo mi scrivono i medici e
gianluca come va ti ricordi quella start
up che avevo fondato st colleghi al sito
del nasdaq tra due settimane ci quoterà
in borsa è in quel momento mi sono
sentito io quello scemo e per anni in
quegli anni li ricordo la frustrazione
di vedere che tutte queste start up che
nascevano in silicon valley san
francisco non esistevano in italia non
esistevano nemmeno in francia in
germania tutti i miei colleghi ci
chiedeva ma come mai
seguono è il problema forse noi non
siamo capaci
forse si vuole è che siamo minorati che
abbiamo siamo meno bravi dei nostri
colleghi americani forse ste cose
succedono solo in silicon valley ed è
stato anno e dopo quando ho incontrato
il sellino che ho capito che ho capito
che tutte queste aziende non nascevano
perché non c'era il venture capital è
così uscito da quell esperienza
imprenditoriale
ho deciso di cambiare pelle la terza
volta ad imparare un nuovo mestiere e di
passare dall'altra parte e fare io
vincer capitale quindi così come io ho
avuto la fortuna la possibilità di fare
la mia impresa e di creare centinaia di
posti di lavoro in giro per l'italia ci
sarebbero stati migliaia di ragazzi
molto più in gamba di me che con i
giusti soldi e intelligenze e capacità
avrebbero potuto fare anche meglio di me
abbiamo comprato un camper
abbiamo cominciato a girare l'italia a
insegnare ai ragazzi nelle università
nei covor king come si fa una start up
come si fa un business plan come si
parla con l'investitore cosa devi fare
quando inizi e ho incontrato centinaia
di migliaia di ragazzi in questi anni
abbiamo visto nascere intorno a noi
un'intera cultura imprenditoriale
ora questi andate di innovazione che
colpiscono la società alla velocità a
cui la tecnologia si sta sviluppando
stanno producendo effetti è sempre di
più sarà così in scala logaritmica
quindi è un po come quando noi il punto
nasce uno da noi siamo lì a guardare il
mare e non da in lontana sembra una
piccola increspatura quasi non ce ne
accorgiamo il problema che se facciamo
finta di non vedere che c'è quello che
sta per arrivare nel momento in cui
vicino a noi è uno tsunami che destinata
frontalmente a spazzarci via per cui se
tu 20 anni fa faceva il tassista e
vedevi questa roba di internet dice
governo è internet non mi farà niente
faccio il tassista e quindi te ne stavi
tranquillo su showtime sul suo taxi
lo sapevi che poi c'era un ragazzino in
uno scantinato in una birreria che su un
tovagliolo di carta aveva notato che
arrivavano gli smartphone che sugli
smartphone c'era il gps è che google
aveva lanciato google maps e quindi si
poteva creare un'azienda di nome huber
che avrebbe ripensato completamente la
mobilità e avrebbe cominciato a
immaginare in un mondo in cui tassi lo
saranno neanche più guidati dagli uomini
ma verranno chiamati da un'applicazione
arriveranno direttamente a prenderci e
le aziende fanno spesso questo errore
che le aziende sono abituati a fare le
cose sempre la stessa maniera per cui se
tu
se leader al mondo gli alberghi cioè 80
mila stanze c'è un brand pazzesco e
canali distributivi le truppe cammellate
e le infrastrutture non ti rendi conto
che ci sono tre ragazzini che con un
tovagliolino di carta sta scrivendo un
business plan perché hanno cominciato ad
affittare il loro materassino gonfiabile
dell'appartamento per arrotondare lo
stipendio e quando te ne sei accorto 180
milioni distanze fanno un business dieci
volte più grosso del due senza
infrastrutture senza truppe cammellate
e a quel momento è un po un problema
riorganizzare tutto il tuo business e di
fronte al cambiamento di fronte
all'innovazione siamo sempre con questo
atteggiamento binario ci mette cambiare
ci dà fastidio a cambiarci preoccupa
abbiamo paura del cambiamento il
cambiamento ci mette in una situazione
di difficoltà non sappiamo se saremo
spazzati via dal cambiamento però nel
cambiamento ci sono quelli che invece
vedono tutta un'altra cosa e vedono
un'opportunità uno spazio che si apre
per fare qualcosa di nuovo per cambiare
il mondo per fare un'impresa per creare
posti di lavoro e ne ho conosciuti
tantissimi e queste sono le loro facce
il problema che quando avevamo iniziato
15 anni fa a girare col nostro camper
una decina d'anni fa
ragazzi come questi non trovavano
ascolto non riuscivamo a convincere
nessuno a investire nelle loro idee
nelle loro start up per cui se ne
andavano in silicon valley questi tre in
specifico non so se avete visto
mattarella qualche settimana fa sono i
tre fondatori di kong e finanziata dagli
stati uniti da commenda gli angel
investor dei fondatori di google oggi
un'azienda gigantesca che a centinaia e
centinaia di dipendenti ma grazie a
internet la cultura delle start up si è
diffusa anche in italia e oggi ci sono
qualcosa come più di 50mila ragazzi che
stanno facendo una start up e che hanno
un'idea su un tovagliolino di carta e
stanno partendo gente come vito lo mele
tra l'altro mio amico pugliese che ha
fondato jobrapido è diventato il più
grosso motori di ricerca negli annunci
di lavoro al mondo l'ha venduta
un'azienda quotata inglese gente come
davide dattoli che sta creando con tag
una rete di coworking tutta europa in
cui si trovano gli innovatori scambiano
le loro idee a volte le start up non
funzionano a volte falliscono e ugo
parodi e con mosaico non ce l'ha fatta
ma quello che rimarrà
nonostante mosaicon è andata male e
proprio ugo parodi e dopo il fallimento
uno come parodi rifarà l'imprenditore è
sicuramente la prossima volta più forte
di prima avrà successo o le start up non
hanno paura ai fondatori di satie spay
avevano molto chiaro che grazie a sepa
avrebbero potuto fare un sistema di
pagamento completamente nuovo e non
avevano nessuna paura di concorrere con
le grandi banche o le grandi carte di
credito o a volte le start up vogliono
cambiare il mondo come i fondatori di
sarde che con la moneta alternativa
dalla sardegna stanno in tutta italia
creando un nuovo modello di economia una
nuova idea del denaro un nuovo modello
di sviluppo economico territoriale
ecco questo è il venture capital e
questo il mio mestiere secondo me è il
momento di smettere di fare quello che
facciamo sempre la stessa maniera il
momento di cominciare a investire
nell'economia reale e del momento di
cominciare cominciare a investire sui
dei nostri figli
grazie
[Applauso]